What I would like to do in this episode is to achieve
Conditions conducive to the continuation of the vector field
Or integrated line with vector and
Be independent of the path
Let me assume I will take this line
Integrated along the "C" path of point "P" "D" "T",
Let's say the path looks like this
Here are the cursed "X" and "Y" and say that the path seems to be
So: Let's start from here and then end up
Point "C"
Endpoint, the curve here is "Si"
So I will evaluate the integrated line, the field of this vector
Along the track
This is an independent vector
Or we can call it a conservative vector area, if it is equal
The same is integrated for another different track
Which he shares with him at the same end point
So let's call it "C1" and this is the "C2"
The vector field is conservative if it starts
From the same point but by taking a different path
Suppose I go like this: if I took a different path
But "C2" I get the same value
Hence it is clear to me that all interested in the process of evaluation
These integrations are the starting point and the end point
What do we do?
I also do not care how to start from the starting point
To the end point
Because these two integrals have the same starting point and end
, So regardless of their actual course, they are
They will be identical (same)
This is precisely what P means as a conservative field
What this integral means is that it is an independent track
So before you prove the conditions, let's start building
Tool kit slightly
Let's say you saw or did not see
Multi - Probability Value Series
Which I did not prove in this episode, but
I think it will be an incentive for you
So I will not need to prove it to you, or I will
In the end, but I want to inspire your conclusion
All it says is that when I have certain jobs
I have (for example) "P" from "X" and "Y", but "X" and "Y" are two functions
The third, "v", so the "q" of the "x" of "v" and "y" of the "v", this is
Derivative (branching) due to multiple differences
I now have two variables in the "X" and "Y"
This will be equal to the fraction of the "P"
For "X"
The speed range that does not change with the change and X times is derived from
Regarding T - this is the only variable function
Here, you can even take a regular derivative.
Calculate the speed of the "X" change for "T"
This is a standard derivative, this is a partial derivative,
Because at that level we deal with two variables.
We have not finished yet. - In addition to the speed of changes and in relation to
B "Y" Calculate the variables "Y" for the "T"
"DDT"
I will not prove it, but I think it makes
Good intuition.
This is to say, whenever we move DT a bit, and what are
The value of "A", "P" and "any" we get
Or how fast is this change and regarding t?
She says, well there are two ways and can change
For "X" or for "Y"